these are one of the very first
in-studio guests we've ever had back in
the day Chris Bravo
yes hosted the show they've done it all
here that's right it is a pleasure to
have Jason and Randy Sklar back here on
show love it and in your new adventure
poop talk yes documentary about poop in
theaters nationwide released last Friday
do I say drop this class we're happy
about it available on video on demand
worldwide itunes amazon wherever you get
so what do we want to talk about first
sports or poop
let's get poop out of the way yeah
that's always a great feeling to just
get I mean we were like this is a
discussion that is inside of us and that
we had to let go of yes we have everyone
not to get political but everyone
releases their own memo just get it out
there without read a - tag hash tag hash
tag meat poo alright so yes meat it's
part of the walk me through the the
concept of deciding you know what we
need to sit down a bunch of celebrities
and ask them about pooping celebrities
you know this because you did comedy
rich this comedians are amateur
anthropologist we study human behavior
you say this is what's funny about it
and then we reflect it back to the
audience with a take and with some
comedy mixed in so we had Pete Holmes
who's a comedian whose fantastic star of
crashing male Nanjiani Eric Stonestreet
all these people different attitudes
towards pooping represented and our
friend came to us originally we didn't
have this idea this wasn't the movie we
set out to make when we started so it
morphed it finally came what it was
someone can our buddy Eric our buddy
Aaron Feldman who directed the film said
he came to us in I want to make a movie
about the history of poop well you guys
helped me make it and we said no and we
said well what if we could make a movie
with our funny friends yes make it an
honest open discussion about poop which
really becomes a story about taboo
subject that something we all do but we
don't talk about we pretend we don't do
it in this tinder facebook profile
picture where we are all sort of
becoming our avatar which is a high
angle selfie just with like
amazing filter put on it we don't want
to let the world know that we sit down
and squat it out but everybody does and
to me that is the moment when we're most
human the most human that we are and
what guys fans Wolverines fans on this
issue
yes but Buckeyes fans call it the
pooping in the shape of a horseshoe all
right but it was fascinating to do
really fun to do we kind of learned so
much about our friends friends that
we've known for 20 years yeah you're
talking about this stuff with them that
you would never normally talk about Edie
suddenly you're learning stuff about
them that we would never know and so it
was very revealing and and and just a
lot of fun to do we made it on a
shoestring budget released in theaters
we went to the theater in in Santa
Monica and watched it for opening night
the opening thing we did a QA afterwards
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was it was actually really cool that
that no one in the all the people in
theater were strangers people came to
this movie and it wasn't friends and
family it was kind of cool know us
stories like we all do I mean I'll never
be here we just showed a clip to our
television audience a Randy and Jason
Sklar here the authors if you will is
that the proper way or the driving force
that we just showed a clip of Eric
Stonestreet basically saying cuz he's a
public figure totally he will not public
poop it is so because and people will be
able to know there's the guy on her
family did that he's been if he goes to
the men's room and he's back in 60
seconds we all know what he just did
it's about ten minutes we only did a
great run with him at the in the movie
where he we made him list all the
stadiums he hasn't pooped at he's not
yes he keeps coming back he's like I've
never pooped
never pooped at Qualcomm never pooped at
Levi's be no I've never pooped in
Staples Center he's like I worked in
college at bram legit it's a date I
never pooped at Bramblett it was just
great they won't do it why wouldn't do
it either why not what do you mean why
not people I will go anywhere with it
when you have to go yes I go that sort
of control is what you're saying right I
mean Wow
if you had to go you would go here's
here's the thing okay and I think
everybody who's listening to this show
and watching it will understand a men's
room is so much more different than a
woman's oh yeah I mean it's not like
I've been to you know and hold on there
are times when my four year old
daughters gotta go yeah I knocked the
door on and I'm like is anybody in here
and I take her in there and I walk in
and it's gorgeous it's ours oh there's
artwork smells good and and yeah there's
artwork that there's there are actual
tile it's just like it is like that
Seinfeld episode where we're nowhere
Costanza walks in and it's just the
models are all over the incredible yeah
we men are just we're animals animals
and so I will not guys will not lift a
seat when they've got to go one it's
terrible it's awful and you gotta get it
goes right through you what do you do
you just eat Mexican close to home yes
rich just plans out where it's gonna I
know that's what this movies about being
open and honest should I share
completely one time at a sporting event
mm-hmm in my life my life is Super Bowl
one time the pooper Bowl the 1999
all-star game in Fenway Park like
haunted by the ghosts of RM Ski took
some monster dumps they were the worst I
still smell Johnny Pesky 'he's big
on his route Big Papi he just just come
on these Sklar brothers here on the
Richards show this is also too when I
don't care because we're on in red in
California - yeah we are hi my
first-ever news director in the TV
business so in Redding California I
would have to do my own makeup of course
our salmon market on market 1:30 you'd
have to so you know I'd like this this
compact or whatever you want to call it
and I just dab it cuz nah but that was
just back when I had a flowing mane
please so I didn't have to do is nearly
as much as much that's not going all the
way back here no there's exactly okay so
I would go are beyond the air at five
o'clock I do the five o'clock sport so
it'd be far I beat my hit would be
pretty much 5:20 every day yes like
clockwork
right so I would go in around 5:10 and
I'd go in and I'd you know I'd do a
little touch-up
yeah in the one men's room in the entire
small spot of KRC our TV the news
director who also was the on-air a host
of the 5:30 show had his own routine on
occasion when by on occasion I mean
every freaking day
Wow happened like clockwork because I'm
sure regularity is something you guys
talk about so he would he would go every
day into the men's room ten minutes
before I would and just and but and and
and wreck the place yep he want to take
the Browns to the Super Bowl he would
every single year every single day and
there'd be the dog pound
[Laughter]
barking barking barking understand here
is here is the kicker than here's the if
you will cherry on top he would walk up
to the sports desk there was one desk me
with my colleague Mike mangas the
sweetheart of a man who would be the
number one guy and he would go
unabashedly searching for the sports
section yeah there it is that's his tell
that's his tell that's a bad looking for
the Sports Center why do you need to
read that man because he was my boss
I didn't one time call him out know one
time I actually saw him walking over and
I just rolled my eyes without him seeing
and I just here it is at a time when
people read the sports section of
newspapers back at that time when they
did that and you did your part to make
sure that that big instinct but look at
this movie it made you think this moment
made you think about your career
beginnings your humble beginnings roots
theraph as a human movie the fact that I
would be able to you know I guess in a
way that raised the level of difficulty
to my first ever sports cast that made
everything else that much easier if you
have to go through the gauntlet think of
what the guys from Shawshank Redemption
had to do that every day let's take a
60-second break we'll talk sports
adjacent you were kind enough you were
amazed I paid my man you represent
represented you or maize did didn't you
were kind of a little bit of blue didn't
want to be too on-the-nose there was a
little bit of blue in here all right the
the barber brothers of poop here I want
to be Rhonda btq we're back with more on
the Rich Eisen show in 60 seconds
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show the
docq comedy poop talk Randy and Jason
Sklar at Sklar brothers on Twitter here
on the Rich Eisen show you guys are just
we said it and that's what we want
people to go see the shape of lady turd
I would have said lady to all of it
works we're all sort of building off the
Oscar buzz now you're making me think of
different ways to say it be
oscar-nominated films get out would you
speak I'm writing it out get it out
there are moments out down to the toilet
my god
the darkest hour the darkest hour
darkest hour okay so you hardball
reached out to you to host signing with
the stars in 2017 right yes we did that
and that was really fun I mean it's
crazy to write comedy for that event cuz
we came up and did some jokes though cuz
we it was at Chrysler arena arena right
so there we were in Chrysler and we
remembered back to when we were there
post you being there yes we camped out
when the fab 5 were there we the first
year they changed the ticket situation
where you got a card and you could sit
wherever you wanted as long as you got
an early so we camped out and when did
you graduate mission 94 94 we camped out
and we this is 92 for the Duke game Duke
mission that amazing Duke game that was
in the documentary everything and our
joke was you brought the joke yeah we I
remember when we were back there and
can't be happy to do a game we walked
into the Chrysler arena and a
two-year-old Grayson Allen tried to trip
us someone was like and then they kind
of made a know we're like did that go
too far did that cross the line cuz
actually there is a referee in Columbus
who thinks it was a few inches behind
and they didn't cross alive
today an hour and 20 minutes later we
had so many d-backs who joined the couch
it was a lot there are a lot of d-backs
to be recruited yes that I didn't
realize that they had all moved over to
the end of the couch and I went to sit
down in front of 6,000 people no couch
behind out tripped and fell goes to
Grayson Allen Tripoli Oh some days you
don't make jokes about that guy you do
not joke about it it was fantastic
though there had to be an hard buck did
you he was super cool afterwards I asked
him I was like you know just walking up
through the tunnel of Chrysler to get to
the the press room the press room where
he's about to give the press conference
after what just happened and I said hey
man how's your son he just had a baby I
was pretty recent I was like hey he's
like oh my god take up phone and show me
the pictures and I said jokingly I said
I heard when you when the baby was being
born you asked to actually deliver the
baby and then you check the defense and
you handed it off to Eddie mcdu him on a
jet sweep he thought that was the
funniest thing I've ever said and then
he used it in the press conference I can
I use that we're like sure he was great
he was such a nice guy we talked about
this before it's gonna be an interesting
year in college football certainly if if
all those guys from Ole Miss are able to
play right away just play right away
it'll landscape a little bit yeah
certainly the quarterback how good is
the Big Ten East it's not a crazy insane
well listen you know that I'm Michigan's
the only school that has to play
Michigan State Ohio State Penn State
every year in Wisconsin almost every
year in Wisconsin that's always that's
always dicey that's always dicey because
they're just there's like so much energy
in there they're right underneath the
hospital you got to look right up and
everyone sits on the best moment in all
of football like how do you beat that
team after they do something so
beautiful like that it's very difficult
I know I get asked all the time what do
you think's gonna happen with the
Harbaugh what do you think but here I'm
like he's not going anywhere I don't
think he's gonna because I don't think
he wants to go anywhere and and truth be
told if they have a good season then I
mean look this is a great weekend for
Michigan Sports in that the basketball
team beat Ohio State a hockey team beat
a number one Notre Dame team to sort of
and secure their sort of position and
also
yesterday Brockman Michigan no.1 the
2013 NCAA I mean Louisville vacated now
speaking of poop talk now what would
would you raise a banner no no way I
can't you can't raise something you can
I do
Louisville removed the banner yet they
haven't removed it you don't think it's
been removed
I think Louisville should remove the
banner cut it up and make it tablecloths
for the Italian restaurant where Rick
Pitino had sex with that woman for 15
seconds just use make it a tablecloth
some white that it's a little white and
that's the worst Billy Joel song I've
ever heard that yes a China Italian
restaurant yeah see in Italian are you
watching the Olympics are you are you
need deep into Italy I know these guys
what's what's lasted longer from these
Olympics the curling competition or Rony
Seikaly Syracuse basketball career I
don't know cycle is still a DJ on Greek
cruises because to me usually short
shorts usually a sport in the Olympics
it starts one day and then four or five
days later it's done I love curling so
much because it's quiet in the arena
I love mixed pick we love mixed pairs
currently because first of all they're
all engaged or married because how could
another individual break the bond
between two cochlear just love to see
and I'm waiting to see like a mixed pair
curling team that's on thin curling ice
in their marriage and like because it's
inherently a domestic dispute because
someone's sweeping and doing the stone
and the other ones gotta yell at him
sweet honey I'm sorry using a tone with
me why don't you read the emails I want
to be sweeping right now you're the one
is gonna sign up for the parent-teacher
like you sweep when my mother comes in
town and you do and you ignore
in the corner the houses are the stones
in the back of the house you play with
my stones somebody drops the hammer
divorce attorney comes and drops the
house divorces because you can hear
everything they're saying to each other
it's my favorite I would absolutely why
men just the all day long the
cross-country skiing is incredible
that's how about the guy who fell and
then came back in the crust and I think
he fell in you're like this guy's done
and he comes back and wins the whole
thing I that was I didn't think I'd be
that excited about watching crust or the
snowboarding American snowboarder who
did the giant slalom skiing the look on
her face when she realized on her second
run yeah she wasn't even in the top 15
and then she won right like a hundredth
of a second and she just stood there
like I cannot believe I just did that
amazing yeah I've been I've been into it
it's been cool I love watching with the
kids too and I kind of wish Fergie would
sing everyone was just jazzy good I was
like I think here's my price this is my
theory about it
Fergie because they sang this the Black
Eyed Peas sang a song where they said
Mazel Tov yes I'm sure they're getting a
ton of rich Jewish families from the
Miami area for the for the Bat Mitzvah
she has gotten into that mode of just
playing tons of barnbaum it's was she
now is just in this jasmine like what
have we seen from the Black Eyed Peas
ruse that not a lot knows on the bar
mitzvah circuit you got to jazz it up
and that's what she's been doing and
that's what she tried I said flavors
that why team LeBron was introduced for
the candle lighting he said LeBron
stepped up the Megan said when you live
so far away bubbie and Zayde e come up
the next panel go on drawing today Susie
and I my wife and I sat behind Goran
dragas parents laminal who could barely
say two words in English and well
they're so happy except I did I did help
them out because two people during the
introduction of the players yeah stood
up in front of them and Susie and I down
in fronted them you down on the drug ad
and the draaga just turned to us and
that's they might not have understood
the language yeah nonverbal but it's
international that sit the hell down
data down in front got Rogich approval
went Rogich you made it a seven-point
LeBron team LeBron lead with five
minutes to go in the first quarter they
were my gosh Sklar brothers on twitter
check out poop talk everybody in
theaters nationwide and also available
worldwide on video on demand thanks guys
think he's doing traveling anytime come
back what the hell else am I not
promoting podcast view from the cheap
seats which will have you back on again
that's our sports one in dumb people
town there you go okay great great
you know me I'm gonna speak to my wife I
think talking poop talk on my podcast
with my wife would be killer
well why it would be a rely see I know
she would love it the shape of toilet
water I like it
check it out the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience